everyone i'm your new commanding officer
captain ray holt speech that was my
speech
short and sweet you wanted to see me
captain yes the d.a wanted me to
personally thank you for your work on
the j
street drug bust that's why we do this
sir for praise
uh there's a community outreach program
that's very important to me i was
wondering if you'd like to head it up
absolutely sir i won't just head it up i
will head and shoulders it up
i will dive in swim around it and just
be
all together good with it be more
articulate when you speak to the
children
yes sir i will make better mouth
it's no secret the nypd has an image
problem
yeah when i told my garbage man i was a
cop he said gross
he had someone else's band-aid stuck to
him police approval ratings are
part of my language in the commode all
the headlines are about the bad cops but
they're
good cops too and i want to put up
posters that showcase some of our best
i'd like you to be on the first one shut
up ray
i mean interesting captain
i'll think about it wow this is a bad
idea first off
amy has an epic lack of swagger uh i'll
have you know i have swagger
i ooze swagger
i want all paperwork on your closed
cases by tomorrow scully you can just
write i didn't close any on a piece of
paper
you got it i already got my paperwork in
captain
then i guess this little reminder isn't
for you wow
looks like he hates you even more than
me no he doesn't we have a good
relationship
we're on the same page something to
share with the rest of us santiago
no sir i wasn't peralta was the one that
was talking
god you must have been the worst fourth
grader ever joke's on you
i skipped fourth grade santiago anything
else
no no dismissed
it's a great picture sir i hate it
me too
[Music]
so i have an eyewitness in the person at
your case only problem is the sketch
artist is out sick
how do you want me to proceed figure it
out santiago it's your case
yes i will do that thank you
are you bowing no
this is how i walk knock knock
you can knock with your hands saying it
is ridiculous
okay well i know you're having a bad day
i think you're having a bad day so
to cheer you up i had terry do this
painting
to replace the photo you hated i threw
away the photo because i think it's
ostentatious to hang pictures of
yourself especially when you haven't
earned a place on the wall
but you would have me hang a baroque oil
painting of myself like i'm a north
korean
dictator what no ornate gold frame
why am i not astride my noble steed clad
in armor
we could add a horse you just wasted
your time terry's time and now my time
on this when you should have been filing
a report on the purse snatcher
oh i did it's already in the system no
good thank you dismissed
can i help you santiago oh captain
i didn't expect to see you there in my
office
so i just wanted to make sure that you
knew about the thanksgiving dinner i'm
hosting for the squad after work
yes i received your save the date
decorative gourd
your ornamental cornucopia and this
beautiful handcrafted card of a turkey
wearing a top hat
it's a pilgrim's hat where's the buckle
santiago
my husband's out of town for work so of
course i will
i attend your dinner cool whatever
yeah don't worry about it either way
it's not a big deal
captain holt happy thanksgiving your
apartment was very easy to locate
thank you so much you look beautiful
weirdest conversation ever nice work you
two
captain um i want to tell you something
i think you're
like when i was a little girl you think
i'm like when you were a little girl
forget it the moment's best is this
about your toast
how'd you get that gina gave it to me
very well written
there are several compelling anecdotes
the fonts suit the tone
good work i did feel however the word
choice could have been improved in spots
i mark them
awk for awkward
okay this is the junior police program
aka mission possible
your mission should you choose to accept
it is to get your life
back on track oh narc
hey gina what are you doing oh hi amy
since i have nothing to offer since i'm
not a cop i thought i'd just
show up and learn you want to help me
out here no i think i'm good
i know you think getting in trouble is
cool
but let me show you what can happen if
you continue down this path
hey yo i'm an at-risk kid and i think
it's cool to sell drugs
hold up why does a kid selling drugs
sound like he's black he's not
well why not are you saying that black
people can't sell drugs
no i'm not saying that we have a black
president why can't black people sell
drugs
i'm so confused black people can sell
drugs
black people can't sell jokes black
people
can't sell drugs black people can't sell
drugs
black people can't use your glasses
they're gigantic my contacts dried out
thanks to you and
they're cool no they're not wow you are
blind blind
yeah you're a blind cop how's there not
been a made for tv movie about your
struggles
gave this back yep wow
ah welcome captain raymond
those slacks are a knockout come on amy
time to put my newfound knowledge to the
test
so sir popcorn setting always too short
am i right
i'm sorry on our microwave we have the
same microwave
oh i didn't buy it it um came with that
thomas thoughts i have
no thoughts about hummus if you'll
excuse me
blink twice if you'd like me to mercy
kill you i thought i had done enough
recon but clearly i've only scratched
the surface
if i'm gonna bond with him i have to
massively violate his privacy
we should have just gone out for dinner
to a restaurant like we do every year
why did you make me invite them i made
you invite them because i like them
they're good people
santiago are you hiding in my bathroom
with a dog that you're deathly allergic
to
no
[Music]
occupied
hey i saw you earlier you weren't in the
bathroom
you were on a park bench playing on your
phone yeah
you left me to do everything well i
thought you were pooping
i wish you were pooping i wish to god
i'm sorry oh
rosa crying don't know what to do
pat pat this feels wrong we put away
figgis three weeks ago
pimento should have been back by now we
had plans to meet on that park bench
once the coast was clear
he hasn't shown up maybe he's deep
undercover or
he doesn't remember who he is or maybe
he's dead wow
thanks you're right my fiance is a total
weirdo who's probably dead
i'll just give up on him and go do my
paperwork no
diaz wait maybe he's just really really
injured
come on amy i'm really sorry
i shouldn't have said that about pimento
i'm sure he's gonna come back
i'm not even thinking about it anymore
that wasn't even me crying in the
bathroom earlier that was someone else
with these same boots but now she's gone
look when jake was in witness protection
and i didn't know when he was ever
coming back
you were always there when i needed to
vent so i'll do your paperwork
and if you ever want company on that
bench i'm there thanks
i would advise against it though if he
does come back things are gonna get real
raunchy real fast
like do a lot of licking that's probably
a decent exposure
okay good talk okay we have got to
explain this thing to captain holt to
save their relationship
and you laughed at me when i went to
that weekend-long math conference
because you called it funky cats in
their feisty stats that was the name it
was so cool
it was not anyway it's not about the
math they haven't seen each other
because of the night shift
they just need to bone what gross rosa
those are our dads
i mean that's not what i think captain
dad is just my boss
wow never mind i'm teaching father the
math
whatever rosa come on sir the math thing
isn't the problem night shift's keeping
you and kevin apart
you two just need a bone what did you
say don't say it again
i said you two need a bone wow
dare you detective diaz i am your
superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective
is none of your business bone
don't ever speak to me like that again
[Music]
why did you do that dude just pen up now
he knows problem solved
you